imposter syndrome how does one move past
it ah sit back
zadi she is an expert in Breaking Bad
Habits and beating addiction Women's
Health Magazine has called her Britain's
answer to Bruno Brown and she's also an
author including the number one
bestseller the kindness method I am
determined to have binge eating and
powerlessness and lack of trust that
people have as a direct result of weight
loss diets to die with my generation why
I started dieting from a really really
young age and I was using food as a drug
when I got to my heaviest I was like
that's it I'm done how have you 126
kilos and it eventually culminated in
secretly getting a gastric band fitted I
started working in addiction treatment
and I started realizing that I was going
about this the wrong way I wasn't meant
to be making my body smaller I was meant
to understand why I didn't like myself
enough to take the same advice I'd give
someone else when someone you love is
struggling to get back on track you
don't pretend that what they're trying
to do is simple and you don't tell them
to throw in the towel and that's where
people feel super disempowered because
they're not taking the advice they'd
give another person
I think people feel patronized because
what they needed was understanding why
if I have all this information and I
want to do this I'm not doing it and
what I always tell them is
if you were to try and identify why some
people are unsuccessful in their change
what are like the overarching themes one
of them is
[Music]
sure can you um
tell me what your sort of academic
professional buyer might say
yeah I did a
undergrad in psychosocial Sciences in
Norwich and then a postgrad in
psychology
and then I went on to work for the NHS I
didn't one year placement as an
assistant psychologist in substance
misuse in Northwest London
and then during that time I was trained
in all sorts of different
evidence-based approaches that are used
to help people to change really
ingrained behaviors around mainly around
opiate and alcohol addiction
now what about your um your personal
context so take me below the age of you
know I'm a big believer on this show
that that origin story and our
childhoods really shape who we become
um tell me about that
well um I was born here I was born in
North London and my parents
um are from Iran and they came after the
revolution or during the revolution
and my first language is Farsi so I
learned how to speak English
and then I moved uh to the states my
dad's work for a little bit and ended up
coming back and during that time
I started to struggle I started to
struggle with um
trauma responses to things and I started
stammering to the extent that I found it
really hard to speak at all at school
and then we came back to the UK and
I started going to school here and I
didn't have a great time I was uh really
overweight kids weren't super nice to me
about it and I started dieting from a
really really young age because of
course it was like
that's what doctors are recommending at
the time and I started to have a really
mean relationship with myself
everything from the way I spoke to
myself to what I thought I deserved to
how unboundary I was like behaviors of
like low
really really low self-esteem to the
extent where I had
a lot of really shameful behaviors a lot
of codependency a lot of anxiety
controlling stuff I just didn't have the
best time at school to be honest
and I didn't like myself at all like
really didn't and now that I work with
people who don't like themselves I could
say with confidence that sadly I was on
the more extreme end of things and
I developed what I now realized was a
binge eating disorder
and where I was eating myself I was
using food as a drug essentially I
didn't know that at the time
and I was eating and eating loads and
then it eventually culminated in me kind
of secretly getting a gastric band
fitted
which gave me all sorts of other issues
lying to people lying to my friends
about it feeling ashamed like it was a
easy way out and then I had to have it
removed
by emergency surgery and it was
terrifying
and when I think now about the lengths
that I went to
and weirdly the fact that I never
thought to change my relationship with
food I always just thought if I was
smaller
the world was telling me if you're
smaller everything everything will sort
itself out
um
so that was the angle I was going in for
plus I I seem to think that getting
smaller would teach me how to change
behaviors which kind of does a
disservice to the whole science of
Behavioral change anyway
and
then I went to work in addiction
treatment uh long story short when I you
know I did my went to UNI made the same
friends I have now
and
I started uh I started working in
addiction treatment and I started
realizing that I was going about this
the wrong way
I was going about this completely the
wrong way I wasn't meant to be making my
body smaller I was meant to understand
why
I didn't like myself enough to take the
same advice I'd give someone else
I didn't like myself enough to think I
was worthy of liking food
I didn't trust what I didn't trust
myself I felt powerless like these were
the fundamental things I should have
been dealing with
so I went to therapy and
I started getting on board with the fact
that I didn't need fixing and then my
habits started changing really really
quickly and I was like wow
you said a second ago you had to figure
out why you didn't like yourself
why didn't you like yourself did you
ever figure that out yeah yeah
well using the tools that I hand over to
people now you know it isn't it isn't a
plug that was the whole thing the reason
I personally
uh didn't learn to like myself
and this will be different for each
person but I my value was wrapped up in
how I looked big time and my size
so if the scales weren't making me happy
then I wasn't having a good day
and as a result I wasn't treating myself
well in ways that may seem unrelated to
other people
but I got into my head that unless you
look like this
you don't deserve
it's almost silly for you to do the
things
that people who like themselves do
acts of self-care
even taking pride in my appearance
all kindness was conditional
on me looking a certain way
why like where had that come from well
all sorts we can start with the fact
that I was you know if your kid in the
90s if your kids being bullied for being
fat then you go to the GP they were
going to put you on a diet they were
going to put the kid on a diet so we're
the best of intentions that was
happening second of all I think the
generation particularly of women before
me
weight loss that I think weight loss
dieting has got a lot to answer for
um in that sense the you know the this
is your goal weight and this is how
you'll look and then reward yourself for
the new wardrobe because then you'll
deserve it women who carry water bottles
are slim and like all that
so it was a time
you know that's what was going on it
isn't just that it was my own stuff and
I should have done more to not that
you're saying that but I think sometimes
people will say like what was it deeper
than that and I just think women
especially at that time like that's all
you got that's all you were shown anyway
successful women women who made money
women who got you know who were in
relationships with people of value or
whatever else it was they were shown to
you as a particular type of woman and I
never looked like that
um
so I just never saw that I just never
thought people like me
did stuff like that
and then the worst bit was some of it
would have been really useful to me
frankly you know like I'm not going to
exercise until I'm thin I'm not going to
drink water I'm not going to take care
of myself I'm not going to engage in the
habits that would actually make it
easier for me so I speak to people now
who are the same who are like
they've sort of learned to put
kindness towards themselves they made it
conditional on achieving a goal
they're making it harder to get there
because the goal will be achieved more
quickly if you take your life off hold
and I learned this I write I I write
about this in the first book
I went to counseling
and I was really really low
this was maybe in 20
you know 10 or something like that
really low
and my North Star my whole life had been
like one day you'll be Slimmer and
you'll be someone who does exercise and
you'll be someone who you know stands up
straight and does their hair and all
that stuff
and then you can do all the stuff
you can start enjoying the stuff because
at this point I was so wrapped up and
not like myself that I wasn't even
listening to like a piece of music that
I liked because I'd be like no no hold
on wait my day is coming
or even if I caught myself having a nice
time like on holiday or something I'd
look down and think oh I'd catch a
glimpse of myself and think well no
actually you'd be having a much better
time if you'd actually
sorted this out
and
what I didn't realize is that none of
those things had anything to do with how
I looked
I just picked up this idea along the way
that I didn't deserve those things
because I didn't see people who look
like me
taking care of being allowed to take
care of themselves and being allowed to
feel sexy and being allowed to feel all
the stuff I just didn't see it
and so then I had a session with my
therapist and she said something that
she was like what if you never change
and I was
so angry I can't begin to tell you and
I'm not a particularly angry person but
I was
really angry with her
because I thought well if I don't change
then I never start living I never stop
being nice to myself
that's what that day never comes so I
came out I started thinking about it
sort of entertained it long story short
spent a couple of weeks acting like if I
don't change I'm never going to change
I just started doing the stuff that I
was putting on hold
and then everything changed
what changed
well what I needed to address was things
like boundaries
things like
uh binge eating having no impulse
control putting a space between Trigger
and response this is what was holding me
back from the results I wanted both
mentally and physically right
so what needed to change is that I
needed to do the sorts of things and
engage in the sorts of habits that
enabled me to put that friction in place
to put a space between
trigger and response and it turns out if
you start from a place of feeling like
and depriving yourself of all the
stuff that makes you feel calm and
positive it's considerably harder to
impose that space and to calmly decide
which version of yourself you want to
behave from
so as such I was depriving myself of an
of a real asset that could have helped
me to do things in a row until they get
easier which ultimately is what I see
all behavioral changes you know I can
see great books on behavioral change in
the background there
um we're all trying to make people do
things in a row until they're easier my
way about it is just saying that if
you're nicer to yourself and you have
the same conversation with yourself in
that space and you do the things that
make that space calm and positive and
feel mature
in the way of self-care and
self-soothing and self-compassion and
affirmation
then you can take it Choice by choice in
the direction of it becoming easier
until you really do update the fact this
this idea this assumption that you can't
do it
and this leads on to the kindness method
which was the first first book you wrote
um very much inspired by your own
experience with weight loss and
struggles there
you work with people that want to change
you know
many of them I'm sure are successful in
that change some of them are
unsuccessful in that change
if you were to try and identify why some
people are
unsuccessful in their change what are
like the overarching themes
ah
sit back so I've got one of them is
focusing on the outcome thinking that
your long-term desired outcome
is going to be
compelling enough on the spot
to get you where you want to be
so you start from a place of desperation
this is it this has got to change I want
this I want the health I want the
outcome I want the progression
and then you forget that that isn't that
isn't going to be enough your motivation
will waver your plans will not go to
plan
and you're going to need to have a
conversation with yourself when your
plans don't go to plan that talks you
into take making a decision you'll be
proud you made the next day so I think
one people wildly underestimate how much
it's about zooming in and getting
involved in and excited about
demonstrating Your Capacity in a row
as opposed to hoping that remedying some
negatives long term will be exciting
enough to keep you on track long enough
to make that habit automatic the other
thing that people do wrong I think is
focus on what's wrong with them as
opposed to their assets
and they and they don't have that locked
and loaded for that moment where they
doubt themselves they want to throw in
the towel and think I can't do this
they need to be ready to have to really
debate with that with genuine evidence
to the contrary
in the spirit of wanting to update it
more generally not just in the context
of that habit
taking life off hold so all those things
I said now everything you're going to
reward yourself with really look at it
and ask yourself if I started doing it
now would it put me in a better position
to do difficult things which is
ultimately what behavioral change is
simple but not easy
the other thing people do is they
um what else oh yeah of course I mean
you've had gobble mate on here that
um they focus on what's wrong with the
behavior that they're engaging in as
opposed to how it's serving them
they look at it as a problem as opposed
to a solution
and not only
does that take away the component of
compassion and understanding that's
required when they're stuck thinking why
am I finding this so hard I have no
willpower I must be stupid or whatever
it is is it also deprives you of
understanding whether there's a problem
that still needs solving when you take
that away
and with compassion
and sometimes people find themselves
filling that Gap with another solution
um as opposed to doing it in a way that
says you know what this behavior is
doing a job for me so if I'm not
changing something's going on and that
needs some Curious compassionate
inquiry
that definitely I think the other thing
is that um
this whole tough love the way you speak
to yourself thing
people
people think that like tough love when
you're speaking to yourself often isn't
very smart love
so if
let's say for example you came to me and
you're like true I'm trying to stay on
track with this plan and I've just
fallen off track
and I'm and my task was to get you back
on track believing in yourself as
quickly as possible
and
equipping you to carry on ultimately
making myself redundant to you
I wouldn't say to you
come on you shouldn't be finding this so
hard
this should be easier it's just like
your teacher told you when you were
little you're just the sort of person
who starts things and doesn't finish
them and then you should start on Monday
you know that's smart it's not smart and
that's where people feel super
disempowered because they're not taking
the advice they'd give another person
that's the important bit here that's the
self-esteem bit we don't have a problem
in knowing how to change habits and
people don't have a problem in knowing
what habits they want to change and how
they would benefit them and now thanks
to many of the books behind you we don't
have a problem understanding exactly how
habit change works
I think people feel patronized because
what they needed
was understanding why if I have all this
information and I'm smart and I want to
do this I'm not doing it and instead of
beating themselves up about it
to delve into the story
how did I come to be this way with
compassion how cool is it that this
isn't my fault but I've decided to make
it my responsibility
how can I use behavioral change as a
trojan horse
and the discomfort I have to sit in
that's unavoidable
short term
urges cravings
to listen in on the way that I speak to
myself and work out whether these
predictable alerts from my body
are turning into commands that I'm
obeying
I just think these are check-ins we
should do
and I wanted to give people something so
that they didn't feel like they had to
wait till things got really bad
and also so it was a private process
that's what the kindness method became
it's basically everything useful I wish
I'd had everything useful I saw in
addiction and then when I went on to
train addiction staff which was my next
job after that and working in criminal
justice just everything useful I saw
with the most
challenging resistant client
myself included bear in mind I start
using this stuff and like iterating use
it on myself using it in different ways
and I put it in the book step by step
just in case there were people like me
who wanted to change habits on their own
terms
kind of checking with the program that
they're running where'd it come from
who's it from do I wanna
switch up do you want to update it some
of it fake news
I think habit change is a great trojan
horse for listening in on the way you
speak to yourself
and debating with it until
it's updated and I'm really surprised
that we don't do that in life
if I've got a really stubborn story that
I tell myself really stubborn you know
something traumatic that happened to me
under the age of I know 10 and has
created a story a narrative in my mind
that is just you know
has control of the wheel is driving my
life my decisions and is driving the
self-talk in my head that's utterly
negative
um you must encounter people who have
that that just can't shake it
is that possible that there are some
things that we just can't
that just have too much power over us
they've changed the circuitry in our
brain to an extent that
you know
we can't change
I don't think people like me
should say yes or no to things when they
don't know who they're talking to with
the size of the platform that you have
to be honest with you
of course there are traumas that I can't
speak to of course I mean I've worked in
addiction with young people in addiction
I wouldn't have the audacity to sit here
and say yeah just and that's that's
actually what really pisses me off my
Instagram sometimes I'll see I'll see
something and I'll be like oh just
replace the negative thought with a
positive one it's like oh wow are you a
wizard
you should be on the news
and but I think one thing I will say is
I have been really pleasantly surprised
by what happens when you appeal
to people's need for evidence disprove
it the stuff we tell ourselves a lot of
the time it's not true
or it hasn't been true for a long time
that's compelling people think they can
disprove it by looking in the mirror and
saying that's not true I love you and
you're amazing and you're fantastic
you're going to be so successful
does that work helps does it some people
yeah affirmations help yeah of course I
think with all this stuff it's got to be
a combination of things I think people
just have to have have to be given the
permission to not be judged to strip
this harmless stuff down you know and do
it in a combination of ways that makes
them feel good you want to do a couple
of affirmations for a while fine when
you go off it you want to do something
else whatever fine I just feel like we
have to hold it lightly and stop calling
it remedial
you're just checking in with yourself
um but no I think listen I was I was a
pretty extreme case and for me it was a
case of saying right which
when you write down it's one of the
exercises in the first in both books
actually when you start writing down
like
one of the things I say to myself when I
fall off track
a lot of people realize that they don't
even use that vocabulary in their
day-to-day life that's not theirs
and that makes it compelling to change
it too
what is it that people tend to say when
they fall off what did you say when you
fell off me oh all of it like of course
I'm not going to be able to do it I'm
weak willed some people can do it that
was just that was a fluke anyway that I
had a bit of a streak uh people like me
don't get things like that
um mainly I'm weak I'm stupid I must
hate myself
because bear in mind all these people
are giving you these like legit reasons
why you should do other stuff and you're
going the other way and telling you that
you're harming yourself and you know
that you are you know I'm powerless I'm
weak I can't trust myself all of it and
then thinking up like Extreme Ways to
sort it out they do that because they
love you though right like that's the
paradoxes they're doing that to try and
help you they're saying you're doing
something wrong you know you're no well
no actually if you think about it like
when you tell someone you when someone
you love is struggling to get back on
track
you don't pretend that what they're
trying to do is simple
and you don't tell them to throw in the
towel you remind them of their capacity
to do something difficult you remind
them of the times they've done difficult
things in the past
and you support them
plus you give them perspective this is
what I mean about the smart thinking too
you don't go oh well you've that one
blip that's you just God gotta just
spiral this is a terrible catastrophe
you say we'll just get back on track and
you know back in the day like the first
thousand times I
had this conversation about self-talk I
used to always use the example in groups
and stuff like
um think of someone you love
write down what you say to someone you
love write their name in the middle of
the page if they'd fallen off track and
you were tasked with getting them on
back on track
and through the discomfort involved in
achieving the most meaningful long-term
goals so their behaviors and the values
are aligning
and people would write like you can do
this you're amazing what can I do for
you it's just a blip you can learn from
it think of all the other amazing things
you've done
and then I would get them to cross their
that person's name out and write their
own name in in the spirit of starting to
say look this is by your own admission
these are the things that you would tell
someone you love
then over time I realized
if I give someone a hundred grand to
motivate someone who's fallen off track
they're not gonna say oh it's because
you're weak and you're rubbish just like
your teachers told you there's no point
starting until Monday
you might as well you know destruct this
whole thing for now you might as well
throw the whole plan out
just because of one tiny blip because
you weren't perfect it's not just kind
it's just not good advice
um yeah I'm just not here for the tough
love
there's this word we use a lot in
society at the moment which is imposter
syndrome
it's really an interesting concept I
mean the word itself the phrase itself
is kind of loaded with a series of
assumptions um that I don't think are
necessarily helpful but
you must
in your practice deal with
a lot of people that are showing signs
of what we know as imposter syndrome
what's your what's your take on it and
really like how does one how does one
move past it well this is a very new
this is a hot take because it's through
an observation the way that I come up
with things is I spend as many hours as
I can speaking to people human beings
one after the other as many human beings
as I can in different contexts and
seeing how they are using these tools
and what's working for them and what
isn't and for imposter syndrome
essentially not
not being able to internalize
your accomplishments feeling like a
fraud which I've had
um
managing my binge eating and my anxiety
differently
helped me
change my imposter syndrome for the
better
and I'm seeing why that is now
I've just started work well now that I'm
so passionate about binge eating as a
result of weight loss diets being a
thing that goes with my generation
um what I've noticed is that when people
give themselves permission to find
whatever they find difficult difficult
whatever it is even if it's subjectively
far more simple than all the things
they're managing to do every day
something extraordinary happens
and
that tends to have a really
extraordinary impact because usually
with the people I work with because I'm
talking about like
booze and other drugs and food and stuff
this little shame and guilt associated
with it so that extra bit we all we all
find it difficult to acknowledge you
know a lot of us find it difficult to
say I was great at this and that's the
end of the sentence without any caveats
or and it could have been
when it comes to acknowledging our say
our professional accomplishments or
academic accomplishments the people I
work with a lot of the time feel so
ashamed and guilty about this thing that
that still eludes them
that's that's the bit they'll be like
yeah I got a pay rise but I still
haven't sorted
is watching and I
might fall down it doesn't let them
really
really internalize and process their
capacity
because well for example I
have written two books that's cool
they've done well
um writing books was not hard for me
doing this this is way this is a you
know being able to not stammer while I
speak to you because I had the
confidence to sit and breathe before I
came in here rather than look at notes
or
only Ben Jesus will understand this but
being able to start a binge and then
bring it back
as opposed to just starve myself for
weeks or whatever I was doing before is
a power and a trust in myself and an
ability to close the gap between what I
why what I would tell other people to do
and what I do and a sense of integrity
when no one's watching
that seeps into every area of my life
but the trick was to allow myself to
find something incredibly difficult that
other people
thought was a no-brainer and not think
that that meant I was stupid or weak but
just that's the way things have gone for
me
I remember sitting with Marissa Pierre
and she said that she's never had a
patient whether they were a sports star
or a you know successful millionaire or
whatever
that believed they were enough in terms
of her patience so the people that had
come to her struggling with something at
the root of it is that they they didn't
believe they were enough in some
capacity
do you agree with that
I think uh yeah I think self-worth
self-worth is something that comes up a
lot and if I come to you and you know
it's clear that I have my self-worth is
in the proverbial bin
I just think I'm a you know
useless worthless
don't deserve anything
um
what's the start of that process to get
me to a better place like where do you
what'd you do with me
so if you came to me it wouldn't be just
the problem wouldn't be I have low
self-worth it would be I want to change
this Behavior yeah right and I want to
change it I've been you know drinking
too much alcohol smoking too much of
that sniffing too much of this
where would you start with me
well we would get an honest Baseline of
where you're at now so that's why in the
book we do like a snapshot letter
without judgment totally private
to just say like I think a lot of the
time we create plans for who we want to
be as opposed to Who We Are
and we use this stuff to find ourselves
and I think first of all you meet
yourself and you get on board with who
you meet
and then I would help you to understand
why you've come to be this way so in
that first step getting yeah you know
getting to understand who I am and
getting on board with who I meet that's
through a snapshot letter yeah so it's
essentially saying here we are today
this is where I'm at this is where I've
got to this is where I'm starting
usually it's quite a Fed Up letter like
something's got to change here we go
but what it does is it sort of anchors
the process and says right this is where
we begin
and then when we start moving on to is
the fact that you already know what to
do
I believe that the people who buy my
books already know what to do and I
believe that a lot of people feel really
patronized when they're told what to do
they know what to do
and if they don't they can Google it
they don't know why they're not doing it
despite wanting to do it
so then we start thinking about closing
the gap between the advice you'd give
another person so I just say to people
what would you like to be doing I don't
give them an A or a B I would like to be
running a marathon every day every you
know every couple of months I'd like to
be fit I'd like to be skinny I'd like to
be a good partner I'd want to be perfect
okay
why why are you here why are we having
this conversation because I'm not I'm
drinking so much hardcore sniffing so
many things and doing all the naughty
things I shouldn't be doing and I can't
stop myself but I know you're right I do
know what I should be doing I just can't
do it okay yeah and in the past when
you've created plans to change yeah
what have they look like
um I've basically thrown all of the
alcohol at my house and everything that
I could possibly sniff and I have
emptied the fridge and put only
vegetables in
and I have
um written it down on a piece of paper
and then a week later
I'm back to all of the naughty habits so
what you've done is you've punished
yourself you've put things in place yeah
to say this has got bad yeah I need to
create this environment and control and
isolate yeah so that I don't do the bad
thing yeah did you establish why what
what you're afraid you might have to
experience if you change did you
identify if you get there
what if it's not as good as you think if
you get there will you have to do all
the things that you've told people
you're going to do when you get there
is the process of getting there one that
you're familiar with no all of that what
do you think you're gonna have to get
through what are you gonna have to prove
what do you what triggers you can have
to respond to differently these are the
things people don't talk about what
self-doubt are you gonna have to push
against and disprove and update along
the way
it's it's not about thinking you're
going to be able to focus on what's bad
and also you should anticipate that in a
week's time you're going to want to use
you should put things in place what can
I put in place to you know this is I
found this really compelling in your
book The because something I think about
a lot you know we think of motivation as
being this like constant people ask
stupid questions like how do you stay
motivated all the time which is again an
assumption that people that are
successful in whatever facet of their
life are able to always feel a sense of
motivation but um how does one prepare
for that
that dip that speed bump that you know
the regression the relapse
it's uh I think the best bet you have is
the conversation you have with yourself
and your plans don't go to plan
and at the I think first of all you
prepare by yeah you can have the best
plans in the world but you should assume
that your plans will not go to plan and
even with the best tools in the world
you should assume that you're not able
to preempt every single trigger
every single challenge
the way that you do it is you start to
reframe challenge as an opportunity to
voluntarily demonstrate your capacity
you're like here we go
I
I'm off I'm off grid right now
and all I've got is the advice I'd give
another person and the conversation I
have with myself that's going to turn
into what I do with my hands well don't
do
and I think that if you really focus on
making that conversation one that holds
firmness and compassion together
then that's the best thing you've got
because what you're chasing there is to
feel smart and calm and proud of
yourself
and you already know what you tell
someone else
so the more you do that and the more you
take that advice
and you see the results obviously and it
actually works the more you start doing
it in other areas of your life and my my
job is to make myself redundant to
people as quickly as possible I think we
should have been taught this at school
we have to change habits our whole lives
like why is life dragging us along and
making us change them when we're all
depleted and desperate
um so yeah I would say it's the
conversation you have with yourself and
the conversation you have with yourself
very often people people say to me like
how how can I hold kindness and firmness
at the same time right so how can I
change habits which involves sitting in
discomfort and craving and urges and
still be kind to myself because being
kind to myself means doing whatever I
want whenever I want to do it
and what I always tell them is it's kind
of like if you let's say you have a kid
and you read an article somewhere and
realized that this treat you've been
giving your kid at 11AM every day for
the last year is actually not very it's
really unhealthy so as of tomorrow
you're not going to give the kid the
treat you know you're not going to give
the kid the treat the kid doesn't know
yet kid wakes up tomorrow it's 11
o'clock you're not going to give them
the treat what's what's the kid going to
do want the treat and and what else cry
kick off yeah
would you blame the kid for crying
no you'd expect the kid to cry yeah it's
used to something
you wouldn't make its life miserable
you'd make it as comfortable as possible
and you just repeat that in a row
until it realizes that it's come out
unscathed
compassion I know why you feel this way
of course you feel this way you deserve
to feel this way you scream all you want
babe that doesn't mean I'm gonna do what
you want
that's the conversation you have with
your body over and over again where you
hold compassion and firmness together
until you've done it in a row until it's
easy
that's my angle and if I it does it does
it help to remove the you know the kid
wants the candy or whatever yeah
whatever the thing the kid was expecting
in the morning does it help to remove it
from the environment
so if I if it's you know I've struggled
sometimes with like I had this like
sweetie draw in my house at one point
and
I I knew I didn't want to eat the sweets
but when something would happen maybe
it'd be late at night I feel a bit
hungry maybe you know a bit stressed I'd
end up in a draw
and so I always always wondered to
myself would it just help to just remove
the drawer just like pour it in the bin
I ultimately did
um
but I'm just wondering if those cues
those triggers removing them completely
is the answer
I have this question all the time about
abstinence and sobriety and whether
you know again there are some people for
whom
it's easier
my Approach is very much more for the
general population and so a lot of the
time it's more you know we all sit in
the middle and I want you to feel like
you can have chocolate in your house and
consume it and enjoy it and not feel
powerless over it so at the core of my
message is you decide what you do with
your hands and any negotiation you have
internally about it is a jumping off
point and doesn't actually make you do
anything and it's an insight into how
what you're telling yourself about the
sugar and what it means and how you'll
feel if you don't have it
if you were trying to build up a streak
and get some time onto your belt yeah
maybe
But ultimately what I would recommend
under those circumstances impose some
friction
give yourself some speed bumps to start
thinking about whether you actually want
to do it so for example if I want to if
I'm working into the night
writing which I love doing invariably at
like 1am I start thinking about
deliveroo and about 3 A.M I regret it
strongly same so with that in mind I
don't just delete deliveroo
call details are out addresses out it's
not because I don't trust myself
it's because I want to put in moments
where I think ah remember you didn't
want to do this do you remember why you
didn't want to do this
make it harder for myself
to do the thing that I don't want to be
doing and easier for myself to do the
thing that I do like back in the day
when I used to hate exercise I used to
go to sleep in my gym kit
so there was just one less thing to do
um so that's like removing friction
exactly versus adding it exactly so I
would if I were you I'd impose friction
first like put that draw somewhere else
and and then when you go looking in
another place start thinking to yourself
God why is that draw it disrupts the
autopilot
that's what's something I struggled with
I I do a lot of like late night eating
and then I always regret it in the
morning because you wake up feeling bad
especially if you've eaten just before
you fall asleep the body hasn't really
had a chance to digest it sometimes you
get like some I don't know reflux
whatever they call it and I've always
wondered how to stop myself doing that
when I have when I have the urge
how do I break that habit I guess what's
the friction that I can add
don't be hungry at that time
true that's you know what sometimes I
get really deep in the Weeds about binge
eating and policy around it and obesity
and how we've got to take down all the
diets and everything and sometimes I
forget to say stuff like don't be hungry
that helps you know like there's so many
like deep psychological stuff and we all
have our own complex relationship with
food and stuff and the that's what's
really difficult about talking about
food
is because it is all the good things too
it really is
and much like with alcohol and Other
Drugs when people people who struggle
and feel powerless around it feel really
misunderstood
because they hate it by that point it's
the bane of their life it's all they
think about all day have I been good
have I been bad
what am I going to have was that okay
conflicting nutritional advice like
let's go out of hand
ladies and gentlemen I am so excited
um to introduce and to announce that we
have a brand new sponsor on this podcast
and it's a brand that I've used for the
last decade
um across business across personal life
when I'm holidaying when I'm traveling
for works even at times when I haven't
had somewhere to live and that is Airbnb
the thing with Airbnb is most people
when they think about Airbnb they think
about the guest side of the the product
they think about staying somewhere and
scrolling through all of the incredible
homes that you can stay in but the
entrepreneur in me has always thought
about the other side which is what space
do I have what space am I living in that
I could add from a supply side and to
create a revenue stream from that's what
I'm fascinated by and I'll be sharing
details about that side of Airbnb in the
coming episodes thank you Airbnb for
supporting us on this show means a lot
you wrote a book about that topic the
last called the last diet why did you
call it the last diet
because I will never gonna die again
well I don't want anyone to go on a diet
again they didn't work
they just didn't work
like whenever anybody says to me like
yeah but so and so is overweight and
it's unhealthy or whatever they have to
go on a diet I'm like well no actually
quite the contrary I'm now working with
people who have not only been left not
with the physical results that they
wanted but have been left with a much
more serious issue
um which is an eating disorder a binge
eating disorder which is wildly damaging
their mental health and their
self-esteem and their ability to enjoy
their lives most the people have come to
me now couldn't give a about losing
weight anymore
they're like remove this lack of trust
remove this powerlessness like make this
end how did this come about and that was
because of weight loss diets in my
opinion on the back of this book it says
this is the last diet you'll ever go on
yeah what is that diet
it's the diet of learning to stop do of
trusting yourself and taking Common
Sense advice now obviously we can we can
go into like whose body what and blood
types and da da da But ultimately the
people I speak to are doing so much
so many of their behaviors are causing
them to gain weight a lot of weight
because of the guilt and the shame and
the All or nothing and the scarcity
mindset and the the Feast of famine that
has come with weight loss diets with the
best of intentions
um and so once they have managed that
and built the self-efficacy that they so
deserve from managing to break the all
or nothing thinking trust themselves
around food learn to enjoy food again
sit in the discomfort of realizing that
they're going to be okay without it get
on board with the fact that they find it
hard when other people don't and build
their self-esteem that way and use the
unhelpful behaviors as a vehicle
to remembering how capable they are
then they can just take the same advice
they would give to another person
because they're not scared of food
anymore and they're not scared of
themselves anymore
and they like themselves so they're more
inclined to make
to make judgments that feel smart you
know I got to a stage where I was doing
diets where someone would show me a
banana and a canister of cream and I'd
be like well the canister of cream is
obviously better for me
that's how messed up and you know what I
know you think it's weird
I assure you I've spoken to enough
people now who are going I know exactly
what she's talking about that's the
extent to which intelligent people start
moving away from Intelligent Decisions
because diets needed us to come back
they needed you to be powerless they
need you to need guidelines or else you
need to pay more and pay someone else
and go find another Guru or get another
diet
as opposed to teach you how to take the
same advice you'd give another person
there is no way that if someone was
trying to manage their weight and they
ate something bad you would say oh well
you've blown it now you should have 15
more
you said earlier you secretly had a
gastric band fitted mm-hmm
well secretly close friends knew but a
lot of my close friends didn't know I
was just done
when I got to my heaviest I was like
that's it I'm done how have you
126 kilos
and then you had it
removed in like a emergency operation
yeah I'm always careful about talking
about it because again I'm afraid that
people are going to be actually you know
what I'm not promoting it by any means
sorry I I know that there are people for
whom it's been really helpful but it did
not teach me to eat differently and the
reason I had an emergency operation is
because my relationship with food was so
profoundly important to me I didn't
understand at the time
that I um
I've never talked to anyone about this
but the band moved
because I overrate
but I kept having it tightened because I
didn't want to be allowed to overeat
because I thought if I've done this to
myself and honestly Steve's like the
pain
it was horrible it was horrible I felt
so ashamed and then I lost a bunch of
weight because it actually can
I won't go into details but it can cause
a different eating disorder I lost a
bunch of weight and I people start being
really nice like you know they reflect
back to you your worst fears
when you lose weight they'll be like oh
wow
we were so worried about you finally now
you can live your life and you're like
I thought that was just me
um and then I felt ashamed because I
thought like I'd copped out
and now I realize on reflection it's
extraordinary that I thought I'd copped
out and you know what the first version
of the kindness method doesn't have that
in it I wasn't ready
I wasn't I hadn't forgiven myself
for being so mean to myself I hadn't
forgiven myself for feeling so shameful
and I hadn't told some of my closest
friends who were there at the time
and I'm sure knew
um that had the grace and the kindness
not to embarrass me
but it was horrible and the day I came
out of surgery I remember with the
emergency surgery
they told me they were going to try and
keep it in
and I remember I came out and the woman
went um
I'm really sorry we had to take it out
and I burst into tears of joy
I hated it
I hated the whole thing I took the lying
I hate the shame I hated the guilt my
body didn't feel good
because even when I lost weight it
wasn't because I was taking care of
myself
it's because I was living living on so
little it just felt like another version
of punishment you know
um it did not do good things for me
how do you how do you feel about that
person that you were that that young
woman who made the decision to fit that
band and went through all of that pain
how did you how do you feel about her
I can't believe how quick she was
to think that people would be upset with
her or ashamed of
or that she should be ashamed
I can't believe there wasn't that extra
layer that said gosh
look what you're having to put yourself
through or you think you have to put
yourself through
there wasn't even a bit of that
it was as though I was born with the
knowledge is as though I had told myself
that I was born with the knowledge to
make the best decisions for myself ever
and if I wasn't then it was a failing on
my part and I was faulty
and I you know I don't feel that anymore
thank goodness
um
you know I think it's also important to
remember that I was all the great things
I am now then that was the point I was
allowed to enjoy my life then so there's
also part of me that's just like wow
it's a real shame
it's a real shame that you didn't kind
of lean into the other stuff because I
was always fun I was always finding I
was always kind
um I wish I had known at that age that
you're allowed to think that you're good
things too
that you know that's okay
what were there any sort of specific
moments or catalysts or dominoes that
fell that created the change you've seen
in your life from the person you were
then to now was there you know if
someone's can relate strongly to that
situation where you're having that
gastric band removed in an emergency orb
and they're looking at the person you
are now
what's what's the piece in between the
actionable piece in between that they
can or even the first step in that
Journey
is it going and seeing a therapist is it
the first actionable step
is
practicing listening listening into the
way you speak to yourself
I think it'll I think ultimately it
comes down to that
I think listen in and the great news is
if you try to change a habit however
small it's an incredibly effective way
to turn up the volume
listen in on what's going on
inquire compassionately curiously what
am I telling myself what am I what are
my assumptions about myself in this
situation
what are my assumptions about what I
deserve curiously write them down think
about whether you'd say that to someone
else
and then start thinking about where it
came from
start seeing whether it's true
just start curiously inquiring because I
think that's the best thing you've got
and it's free
where are you where are you now in terms
of your own self-talk and your own
process and your own perception of self
I am really good I am
this is the best I've ever been
because everything's not great there's a
lot going on and I'm fine
that's why
that's how I know
I know how I would have responded to
things that are happening right now for
two three five years ago this
you know I slept really well last night
am I telling you I kind of felt like
this would go well like this was my time
to tell people what I'm passionate about
and speak to the people who
feel like some people don't get them
um
so right now I feel great because it's
kind of it feels like my nervous
system's kind of got the message you're
safe you're harmless you're just trying
to be nice
and no one's coming for you like
and so far
um the more I'm myself the more it seems
to go all right
which for me personally is of course
considering what I've told you is an
extraordinary thing
and other than what I have to say my
name on the spot which I know a lot of
stammers have
I don't seem to be stammering and I know
that it was a trauma response now
and I think that a lot of the
self-compassion work that I've done has
helped me to calm down
like a lot of this stuff realize that if
I Stam it all the way through this
um it would I'd still be someone who was
worth listening to
that that nervous system the anxiety you
talked about what sort of methods have
you put in place to help you calm down
writing for sure so when I'm panicking
about something most of the time you
know there's that confirmation com
component of just like yep and it did
have you only remember the times it did
happen right so I started collecting all
the things I thought were going to
happen that I was worrying about and
real like just writing them down or just
saying them into my phone and then every
now and then I'd reflect and be like wow
good to know that like I need evidence
you know I need stuff
so I was like all right well the last
100 times you worried about this it did
not happen
and so that helped me calm down
that made it compelling for me
breath work
talking about anxiety understanding
anxiety and what it is and what the
brain's trying to do and about keeping
you safe and all that stuff
and eventually much like you know
whether it's the militant mindfulness
that I come at or the more like
meditative stuff and the more old school
stuff it was essentially a separation
between
uh what I'm thinking right now and
what's actually going on in a curious
compassionate
um look into
why my thoughts are going the way they
are and also it's an understanding it's
a preemption so for example
I should
well I probably won't now that I've said
it which is another thing like get it
out put it in the put it in the light
loads of us are suffering with anxiety
um
to a different degree of course
emptying it made it a lot more
predictable and a lot less personal so
for example the last big
podcast I went on I anticipated I
actually wrote myself a letter before
and I was like after you leave even if
you think you smashed it
you're going to start second guessing
everything you said you're going to
sketch out not want to talk to anyone
about it because they're going to ask
you questions and you're going to think
you forgot something so I just preempted
it I just as we say in addiction I
played the tape forward
and then it started making it more like
oh yeah this is what my brain does to
keep me safe take me back to my place
where I'm used to but actually the last
hundred times it tried to do that I had
nothing to be worried about so I kind of
just realized that I wasn't by myself
anymore I was with myself
and we were working out what was going
on and it got a lot more predictable and
that made it a lot less personal which
made me a lot more calm
and in terms of food
yes
what's your relationship like with food
these days calm
and wonderful I never thought this day
would come I eat what I like
I look forward to eating
I don't feel like I need to justify to
anyone what I'm eating or why I'm eating
it
and great thing happened which for me
you know with writing self-help books
and stuff you know
especially when you're telling people
you're going to change for good and I've
changed for good well I only wrote it
five years ago what do they know you
know so sometimes you have to do things
privately for your own Integrity to be
like oh thank you
and lockdown I put on weight
I didn't eat differently
I didn't feel bad I thought I looked
great and I was like yes I needed this
and then after lockdown I got into
fitness and I've lost weight lost a bit
more weight and I honestly I don't like
myself less or more
so during lockdown what I saw was
um
an example of what it is to just be a
human whose body fluctuates without much
judgment or emotion around food and it
was a wonderful important lesson for me
and I'm really glad now on reflection
even though it wasn't planned
that I did put on weight during that
period because I needed to see that it
didn't matter anymore
and it wasn't because I was neglecting
myself because usually I run around town
all day and I wasn't doing that
and it was so lovely to just have that
be for
regular body reasons and not
shame or guilt or sadness or abuse or
numbing out or whatever
um so yeah I love food now plus
I'm really uh glad no one talks to me
about it anymore because of the book
that I think they're scared to
I mean people don't quite know where I
sit like because I think it's fine for
people to want to lose weight
I think it's really messed up that we
got told for a lifetime especially women
lose weight lose weight lose weight lose
weight oh no you can't go on a diet and
you're not allowed to want to lose
weight you have to love your body
exactly how it is meantime a bunch of us
tried to do what they said and came out
of the diets bigger and with a eating
disorder that makes us feel powerless
even to
um
even to follow Common Sense nutritional
guidelines
so yeah I don't have any problem with
people wanting to do whatever they want
to do it's just that in my case
it came as a result I was never
before a lockdown when I done all this
work and I had all the methods and all
the things I share
there was never a time when I was
overweight because I liked food
or I was enjoying food or it was too
much of a good thing that's why I
understood addiction
if you saw that I was overweight
according to whatever's you know scales
and society and whatever bigger than I
am now
it was always because I it those are the
times I hated food the most it was the
bane of my life I barely tasted it I
know
but the same if you speak to someone who
feels dependent or powerless over
alcohol they're not going to be like oh
I love boots
it becomes when you're powerless
it becomes horrible
and so
there was a space for me to
like myself a lot more when I was bigger
but because I neglected all these other
habits of self-care I wasn't drinking
water I wasn't like just basic stuff
at times when I was bigger it meant that
I wasn't being good to myself but that
is not the case for Everyone by any
means in fact for many people it's quite
the opposite
so that's where I think because it's
quite a nuanced conversation and one
that I've given an enormous amount of
thought to don't get me wrong I didn't
I didn't I wasn't naive about coming out
to talk about things like this I knew I
needed to work out where I sat but I
knew I meant well and I knew I was on
the right path but I had to understood
where I understand where I sat so that's
where now I think people sometimes they
don't ask me about it because they're
not sure
which side I'm on and the fact is it's
both what is your mission now
what's your what's your personal mission
what are you trying to do there's
twofold I want one I want to convince
people that kindness gets done
being nice to yourself and taking the
same advice you would give the people
you love and closing the gap
between what you would tell them and
what you tell yourself and what actions
you would tell them to take and what
actions you take yourself
that's kindness and it gets done
one and two now that I've seen what's
come back from the second book with the
last diet
I am con I am determined to have binge
eating and powerlessness and lack of
trust that people have as a direct
result of weight loss diets to die with
my generation
like it's Gotta Go
because people my age
they know they don't want to pass this
on to their kids no one does
um it's going with me
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest
um not knowing who they're leaving it
for
the question that they've left for you
or is it ever appropriate
to hurt someone's feelings
yes
I think so I've recently hurt someone's
feelings and it was very upsetting for
me as well
but it was appropriate because
it wasn't all mine to carry
and it was appropriate to share
it wasn't nice for me either
but it wasn't all mine
so it was okay to say to them
this is
this is what's upset me about you and I
know it will upset you to hear this
but
I shouldn't be carrying all of this when
you're responsible for some of it
and that will have upset them
yeah
sure thank you thank you so much for
your time thank you for these wonderful
books thank you for all of your work
thank you for the wonderful way that you
articulate and deliver your opinions
it's um it really does cut and that's um
that's exactly what makes for a great
conversationalist and podcaster and I
love your no BS approach to
the way that you communicate and serve
and think because it's uh it's really
refreshing to be honest and that's
pretty much why I I've Loved this
conversation but also I wanted you to
come here because I saw your
conversation with MO
ah yes you have a really no BS way of
articulating yourself which I think is
very much needed um and your your
perspective on on kindness as a method
to many of these things that we're
trying to solve as humans we often
default to like the opposite of kindness
we're mean to ourselves about and mean
to others about I think is I've learned
the hard way that is very much the the
way forward
so thank you so much thank you for
having me
[Music]
you know I never really usually pick the
chocolate flavored heels my favorite are
the banana flavor I love The Salted
Caramel flavor but recently I think I in
part blame Jack in my team who's
obsessed with the chocolate flavor heals
I've started drinking the chocolate
flavor Hills for the first time and I
absolutely love them my life means that
I sometimes disregard my diet and it's
funny that's part of the reason why I've
had a lot of guests on this podcast
recently that talk about diet and health
and those kinds of things because I am
trying to make an active effort to be
more healthy to lose a little bit of
weight as well but to be more healthy
and the role that heal plays in my life
is it means that in those moments where
sometimes I might reach for
you know junk Foods
having an option that is nutritionally
complete that is high in fiber that is
incredibly high in protein that has all
the vitamins and minerals that my body
needs within Arm's Reach that I can
consume on the go is where he always
been a game changer for me
[Music]
foreign
you got to the end of this podcast
whenever someone gets to the end of this
podcast I feel like I owe them a greater
debt of gratitude because that means you
listen to the whole thing and hopefully
that suggests that you enjoyed it if you
are at the end and you enjoyed this
podcast could you do me a little bit of
a favor and hit that subscribe button
that's one of the clearest indicators we
have that this episode was a good
episode and we look at that on all of
the episodes to see which episodes
generated the most subscribers
thank you so much and I'll see you again
next time